since the start of the pandemic physical
retailers have gotten crushed given the
fear of mingling with the public the
appeal of physical locations has
dwindled over the past year causing
dozens of legacy players to file for
bankruptcy including jcpenney j crew
century 21 guitar center pier 1 and many
more
but one retailer who has not only
survived the pandemic but has gone
parabolic is dillard's
since the pandemic lows dillards was up
a maximum of
1409 percent
that's nearly three times their previous
peak and nearly 100 more than tesla's
parabolic run not only has their stock
gone to the moon but dillards also has
the fundamentals to back up this run the
alerts has been posting record profits
and their p e ratio is still under 10.
so here's how one of the oldest and
slowest moving companies was able to
outperform even the most innovative
companies in the world since the
pandemic started
if you're not familiar with dillard's
they're a very popular department store
in the u.s who specializes in clothing
and fashion while i'm sure they have
their own fan base that won't shop
anywhere else as far as the general
public is concerned dillards is just not
a department store like macy's or
nordstrom this isn't necessarily a bad
thing though as most of the competition
doesn't have anything special going for
them on the consumer side either
but unlike much of the competition the
alerts has figured out a way to address
this issue from the business side you
see one of the biggest shortfalls of
running a retail store is the massive
overhead that comes along with each
store you have to pay for leases
maintenance and dozens of employees
regardless of whether you make sales or
not and the given that retail stores
don't have the highest net margins even
the smallest downturn in demand can
leave you unprofitable this isn't
anything new though and alerts has been
strategically combating their shortfall
by owning their stores as of 2011 the
alert zoned 241 out of their 309 stores
many of which they transferred into a
real estate investment trust or read and
today this number is simply even higher
with the dillard only 90 of their retail
space just like us mortals owning large
amounts of real estate as a retailer is
a massive advantage your monthly
payments are building equity your real
estate is appreciating you get tax
write-outs for interest and depreciation
and most importantly you have full
control over your property if a downturn
like the pandemic does hit and you need
to close some stores you can cash in on
your equity or you can become a landlord
yourself on the other hand if you're
releasing you're gonna have to negotiate
and release early and probably pay hefty
fines
all of the most successful retailers
today including walmart and the home
depot owned most of their stores and
they've all been taking the real estate
side of the business extremely seriously
for quite some time now on the flip side
most of the dying retailers don't own
their real estate or they were late to
the game jcpenney for example didn't
form a read until they filed for
bankruptcy last year clearly owning
their stores has been a great advantage
for dillard's but this isn't their only
cost-saving measure either
another way dillards has been able to
establish some stability in the
cutthroat retail industry is leaning up
the business historically dillard's has
been known for being a higher-end
retailer carrying brands like calvin
klein coach ralph lauren and michael
kors but over the past few years the
alerts have focused on appealing to the
middle class and lower income families
as well through their clearance stores
as the name suggests these clearance
stores specialize in selling items that
weren't able to be sold in regular
dealers and these stores have some of
the best deals out there before sending
merchandise to these clearance stores
the alerts tries to price these items 60
off at their regular stores and these
items only make their way to clearance
stores if they still don't sell this
means that only the most undesirable
stuff make their way to clearance
centers but on the bright side these
items are often 70 to 80 cheaper by the
time they make it there delirius
currently operates 30 clearance centers
across the us which has really expanded
it to its target audience and helped
them survive a time period in which many
consumers were more frugal than ever
before aside from appealing to lean
customers the alerts have become much
leaner themselves the alerts owns 100 of
their corporate headquarters
distribution centers and fulfillment
facilities which has minimized overhead
the alerts has also been strategically
closing a handful of stores that weren't
performing as well thanks to these
cost-cutting measures the alerts didn't
have to furlough or lay off any
employees during the pandemic and their
balance sheet has been remarkably
healthy their debt to equity ratio
currently stands at 0.4 meaning that
they have more equity than debt overall
also their long-term debt is only 599
million dollars and their next payment
isn't due till january of 2023.
considering internet income over the
past 12 months itself is 608 million
dollars dillard should not have any
trouble handling this debt as you can
see the alerts has really strong
fundamentals but fundamentals alone
aren't responsible for dillard's
exponential rise
some of the most explosive runs
originated from heavily shorted stocks
and schwartz exited their positions and
it's no different with the dillards once
the pandemic rolled around countless
hedge funds went all in on shorting
recovery stocks you know the restaurants
the cruise lines the airlines the hotels
and of course the retailers most of
these bets played out very well as many
of these businesses straight up filed
for bankruptcy but among these
short-sighted plays the hedge funds
overlook some gems like dillard's and
this would come back to haunt them as
you all probably already know we saw a
massive rise in heavily shorted stocks
near the beginning of 2021 most of the
momentum and hype went into gamestop and
amc but naturally many investors who had
missed out on these plays flocked other
heavily shorted stocks we saw dozens of
posts about dillard's stock or dds pop
up on wall street bets and the dds was
able to recover to pre-pandemic levels
through the gamestop price but it wasn't
until the second round of short squeezes
led by amc that dillards truly went
parabolic now the scc claims that the
ryzen amc and the gamestop was mostly
fueled by momentum as opposed to an
actual short squeeze but regardless of
the specific reason the amc and the
gamestop runs were extremely beneficial
to dillards unlike most meme stocks that
stalled out after the momentum died
though the alerts has continued their
exponential rise thanks to the supply
shortage
most of us associate the supply shortage
with the technology and lumber but the
supply shortage has also carried into
the fashion industry as well now the
alerts hasn't exactly pumped up prices
to the moon like nvidia but they have
been able to heavily cut back on
discounts which carries directly into
their bottom line for most of the 2010s
the alerts net margins hovered at just
under five percent right before the
pandemic taylor's net margins were
actually declining towards two percent
and it of course went negative during
the pandemic but since the start of 2021
dillard's margins have sharply recovered
and reached record levels of 10
most analysts didn't expect such numbers
whatsoever the analyst consensus for
third quarter earnings was 1.93 cents
per share but dillards came in with an
astounding 9.81 cents or 5 times the
expected amount as you would guess this
is the primary factor behind dealer's
recent 100 run in november the alerts
has given back most of these gains over
the past few weeks but many argue that
this is simply a great buying
opportunity the alerts has proven strong
resilience from the pandemic they
control a lot of real estate and they
have pretty strong financials also even
though the revenue has recovered
significantly it's not even back to
pre-pandemic levels yet currently
they're about 5 to 10 away from
pre-pandemic levels and given that a lot
of the competition has dropped out since
the pandemic it's very possible that
dillards is able to outgrow their former
self it should also be noted that even
after a 14x run the lyrids is only worth
5.5 billion dollars meanwhile lululemon
pulls in roughly the same profit but
they're worth 10 times more coming in at
53 billion dollars the lyrics doesn't
have nearly as much hype as lululemon
but considering lululemon's valuation
it's not crazy to think that dillards
could grow to a 15 to 20 billion dollar
evaluation at the same time though many
aren't nearly as convinced by dillards
here's the thing the alerts may have
strong fundamentals but at the end of
the day they're still just a strong
company in a dying industry year after
year balls are seeing less and less foot
traffic and people are becoming more and
more willing to buy everything online
dillard's is also decently competitive
on the online side of things but if
e-commerce is the future it makes little
sense to operate such massive stores
when most customers are just coming in
to pick up an order or return an item
something else they consider is that
even though dealers will face less
competition as competitors drop out
their real estate may also drop in real
value virtually all of dillard stores
are located in malls which garner their
appeal from offering customers a wide
range of shopping options but as
competitors go out of business there
will be less tenants looking to lease or
buy property in these malls the
properties will continue to go up in
nominal value due to inflation but it's
very possible that they start to lose
real value in the upcoming years also
real estate itself has gone parabolic
over the past two years so as real
estate cools down dealer's balance sheet
may start to look less bulletproof but
by far the biggest concern is the supply
shortage resolving right now the markets
are extremely inefficient but this
should just be temporary many analysts
argue that it's just a matter of time
until dillards is forced to be more
lenient with their discounts and their
profits start to fall again to
pre-pandemic levels but anyway at the
end of the day dillards was in a
relatively strong position when the
pandemic hit they owned their stores and
they were leaning up their business
combine this with the meme stock craze
and the supply shortage and dillards was
able to skyrocket 14x but though
dillards has strong financials right now
it's still heavily debated if dillards
will be able to carry on this positive
momentum or if this is simply their last
hurrah before their eventual demise
which camp are you in comment that down
below also drop a like if you think that
shopping for clothes in person is way
better and of course consider joining
our discord community to suggest future
video ideas and consider subscribing and
see more questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one